welcome to
lecture three today we're gonna talk
about uh today and on wednesday we're
going to talk about
time preferences and particular sort of
theory
uh we're going to talk a lot about a lot
of applications a lot of applications
uh that are sort of close to your real
world including like procrastination of
problem sets
all sorts of um other choices such as
credit card debt and so on and so forth
think of can you uh be a little quiet
thank you um think of like the
lectures today and then wednesday sort
of building some framework and some sort
of structure and how to think about
these things
it's a little drier than maybe other
lectures in part because you know it's
about sort of theory and about sort of
writing down a model and trying to think
about the world
partially we're doing that to sort of
try to explain behaviors that we see in
the world partially we do that because
at the end we try to think about sort of
welfare and how to evaluate certain
outcomes is that good or bad certain
policies and things to do
which later in the course we're going to
talk about but for that you need some
structure
how to think about some of those things
at the heart of it
a lot of this is about procrastination
about choices between
the present and the future your problem
set in part is also about
procrastination it will be posted um
later today um um probably late um
please do let us know if you have any um
questions
um as i said you know please be on time
do the readings there will be random
pop quizzes there will be at the
beginning of the class so you should be
on time the laptop section is still over
there if you want to use your laptop it
should be there ideally in the front
in part because you're not going to
bother others
i saw quite a few people using their
phones in class in previous
classes try to not do that that's not
good for you
you will not be able to take away much
from the class multitasking is very hard
for people
to do again i'll show you some evidence
on that as i said the problems that will
be posted shortly
um if you have any questions please do
let us know on piazza
and and help others answer them or
answer them for others
i have office hours usually tuesday
afternoons please sign up for them i'm
very happy to meet you it's very hard
for me to
to meet people
or get to know you in the large class
otherwise so please come to office hours
i'm happy to talk to you
about anything you you're interested in
ideally related to behavioral economics
um okay so let me give you an overview
of like this in the next lecture
we're going to talk first about
exponential discounting why are we
talking about exponential discount
this is the workhorse model of of
classical economics this is how
economists usually
think about like choices over time
second we're going to identify some
problems with this model and trying to
think about like why is this model
perhaps not explaining things well at
least in some settings
and how could we improve on that we're
going to propose an
alternative model which is the
quasi-hyperbolic discounting model
and then we're going to talk about
sophistication and naivete
which is the idea that if you think you
have different or if you think you have
different preferences in the current
uh in the present uh from in the future
well then becomes very important to
understand do you actually know what's
going on do you know that in the future
you might be impatient
or do you perhaps think that oh in the
in the future i will be very patient
um uh and then perhaps perhaps make some
mistakes
accordingly i'll get to this in in more
detail
okay so it's first important to notice
that
any choice essentially almost any choice
you make
almost always involves some choice over
time
essentially some trade-off between the
present between some costs and benefit
that you might occur in the very short
run
and some costs and benefits that you
might enjoy or incur
in the future um what examples do we
have what choices over time do we face
yes savings and how do you decide how
much to save
depending on your preferences
right so you have a choice for example
if you thought think about like should i
save some money let's say for next
semester or next year
so your choice is either to consume the
money now in various ways eat food or
whatever you'd like to do with it spend
it on various activities
so if you save you make the decision to
save you have to give up some
money now and you get some benefits in
the future
the benefits in the future are um
determined by the interest rate as you
say if you have a savings account or the
like you can essentially sort of like
get some benefits in the future
um and then you have some costs in the
present that you know which would be
essentially not consuming now and some
benefits in the future which is getting
that money in the future
and then you need to sort of somehow uh
decide is that worth doing
right there's some costs and benefits we
need to sort of aggregate somehow um
uh whether to make that choice yeah
any other choices you make over time
[Music]
yes
right so i'm actually have this example
here going to school it has some costs
and benefits and what are the costs and
benefits of doing that
um
exactly so you have direct costs of
education which is tuition
in many cases you know sometimes that's
sponsored but often there's tuition it's
quite a bit of money
it's also the opportunity cost which is
often forgotten wages you could be
working otherwise and make more money
there's the joy of pain of going to
school some might think it's positive
some i think it's negative
and then there's future wages which in
many cases at least for you guys are
are tend to be higher from going to
college if you do a phd that might not
be uh
uh the case that i'm not sure that tas
are here but um yes um
sorry for that and then you have to sort
of decide uh are you going to school or
not well what you need to do is like
you sort of need to determine the
utility the value of each of these
costs and benefits right and they occur
in different points in time
you need to make some estimates and then
of course there's risk and other issues
involved you might not have full
information and so on
but assuming that all away suppose you
knew all the costs and benefits of going
to college
then you have to decide is that worth
doing so somehow you need to sort of
aggregate these these costs and benefits
over time by putting appropriate weights
on
different periods and time and sort of
decide should i do this
or not okay yes any other
similar choices that people make
[Music]
yes
right for example you could think about
should i do a problem said should i come
to class should i um
study for an exam and so on often
there's costs and benefits involved
often the costs are immediate uh you
know you have to work on the problem set
that might not be pleasant you have to
study for the exam that might not be
pleasant
you could be doing other uh things
instead that you can't do
because of that and then there's gonna
be like rewards in the future
usually in the terms either through like
you know increased knowledge that might
be useful for other things in the future
or you know through better grades or or
whatever
you might be rewarded from uh having
more uh knowledge
and again then again there might be
uncertainty involved because you know it
could be that
you know you might not fully know what
the costs and benefits are
it could be that it's sort of risky you
might come to class and not come to
class depending on whether there's a pop
quiz or not so you need the sort of risk
involved
um uh but it's sort of assuming that
away there's essentially benefits
of and costs in the in the present and
then sort of benefits and costs
potentially in the future
and again somehow you have to sort of
aggregate these and sort of weigh them
in various uh ways any other choices
yes exercise yeah exactly exercise is a
good one
again like in the present you might not
enjoy it some people might actually
enjoy it a lot i had somebody would tell
me he was like addicted to exercise
that also happens but usually you know
people
at least in the short run tend to not
like exercise that much but i think it's
sort of useful
for them to do in part because they feel
better afterwards
and part because you know they have like
long run benefits maybe they're in
better shape eventually maybe they're
healthier eventually maybe they live
longer eventually and so on and so forth
and again what you need to do is you
have some costs and benefits you have
the cost of like getting ready getting
out of the door and sort of getting
yourself to do it that often is costly
does the cost of exercising itself which
often is costly maybe not
but then the benefits are often in the
future often really far away in the
future
right so if you really were eating
healthy often the same thing like
essentially
you might not eat a like eating like
spinach and vegetables in the
in the present some people of course
love that but often then the benefits
come in the form of like
improved health like many many years um
out
and again what you need to do is you
need to sort of quantify somehow the
costs and benefits of certain actions
and then you need to aggregate the costs
and benefits somehow
to be able to make a choice is that a
good idea or a bad idea do you want to
do this
or not like a number of different
examples here's another
example of like um somewhat very trivial
uh purchasing an expensive software you
have to spend some money of doing it
that's usually entails like negative
utility people don't like to give up
money
second there's like pain and frustrating
of learning the software again that's
often negative utility
and then there's sort of mastery which
is sort of positive utility from
knowing or learning the software until
it becomes obsolete so there's a stream
of positive utility
sometime in the future now how do you
decide whether to purchase a software
well you determine the value of the
utility of costs and benefits somehow
and we're going to talk about in some
degree like how to do that
and then once you have that you need to
sort of weigh the costs and benefits and
try to sort of aggregate and try to
figure out is this a good idea
or not there's another choice um
which we're actually going to talk about
when we talk about welfare and about
policies overall it's sort of
deactivating a social media account in
part because there's a very nice study
that actually studies precisely that
so if you think about like deactivating
a social media account
um facebook twitter or whatever people
instagram whatever people are using
um there's often there's different costs
and benefits involved and you can sort
of
argue about what those are uh part of
that is the direct cost of deactivating
the account often that's a tedious thing
to do you have to
figure out how to do it often companies
don't try to not make it too easy for
you to actually do that
you might want to archive some pictures
or whatever and so on often that's a
tedious thing to do
there's often short run adjustment costs
right you want to kind of like be in
touch with your friends maybe it's
harder to find
out where the parties are whatever or
like um uh whatever things are
so often there's some adjustment costs
likely also negative
and then there's some long-run impact on
your social life and your mental health
and your happiness and so on
that could be positive or or negative
assuming that perhaps they're positive
then again you have to think about like
short run negative costs and benefits
you have to learn about think about what
those are again they might be uncertain
but to the extent that you can tell what
they are then you have like costs and
benefits at different points in time and
when you make that choice you have to
sort of figure out um
whether that's worth doing by sort of
aggregating and aggregating them somehow
uh to some point in time and saying like
yes i'll do it or not
as i said we'll get back to this and i
think something like lecture 20 or so
uh with a fact is a study that was
encouraging people to to in fact
precisely do that and look at sort of
like happiness and other outcomes uh
mental health and so on
among students okay so what are other
important choices
over time if you think about almost
anything that you can think of any
choice that you make in your life
almost any of these sort of involve some
aspects of time
right so if you think about investing
saving borrowing credit card spending
and so on
that involves choices over time if you
think about education
often there's costs in the present
benefits in the future if you think
about any sort of health investments
eating healthy uh taking your medication
brushing your teeth exercising and so on
if you think about sleeping often sleep
involves uh choices between the present
and the future you think about watching
movies at nights that's fun to do but
often that becomes that like pain in the
following day in various forms
uh eating patterns as well uh dating
arguably involves sort of costs and
benefits in the present and the future
people make different choices again
there's all sorts of other aspects
involved as well including like risk
information and so on
but what i'm pointing out here are many
choices that people make have some
aspects that involve different points in
time
and we have to sort of figure out how to
weigh these pref these utility streams
in some ways um uh accordingly
now here's sort of um a broad history um
how economists have thought about this
and it's kind of interesting to to read
in fact and this is what the frederick
at all article
uh talks about um in fact
economists sort of went full circle in
some ways it started with like a very
sort of complicated model of like a
production
the amount of labor allocated to the
production of capital that depends on
the effective desire of accumulation
which is sort of a bit of a mouthful
but essentially there was lots of rich
psychological
considerations involved in like trying
to explain how people make choices over
time
people thought about self-control
self-constraints the request motive how
much they think about their children
anticipatory utility people like to sort
of save because they like to think
they'll be happy in the future and so on
and so forth
and it was a very complicated model of
like intertemporal choice that people
had been thinking about at some point
then like burn barbaric who's an
austrian economist at some point
realized or proposed that the interest
rate
in some sense is just a price so if you
think about doing something or saving
some money
from today until next year it's really
just like
choosing between apples and bananas when
you choose between apples and bananas
there's a relative
price which is the price of apples
divided by the price of bananas
if you think about um uh choices over
time
if you think about consuming a dollar
today versus a dollar next year
the interest rate or one plus the
interest rate is the relative
um price of that right so for any dollar
that i now
consume i could get one plus r dollars
in the future
that's just the relative price of
consumption now versus in the future
so you can think of like the same way we
think about apples and bananas and
optimizing between those
the same way we can think about like uh
consumption in the present and the
future
um um which are just sort of like
different goods uh over time
and so then fisher irving fisher then
came up and said you know
let's just write down a two to good
indifference diagram
this is exactly sort of the indifference
diagram that you've seen in like um
1401 or other introductory micro classes
um
still there were actually many
psychological factors discussed like
personal factors that the the determine
like how much you um
save and so on but it was sort of like
progress towards that
now what is the fischer diagram the
fischer diagram looks something like
this this is sort of what you should be
familiar with from like again 1401
what do we see here what is this
yes
right exactly so we have like here um
choices between two goods i call them
like good a
and good b there's a consumption c a as
consumption of good a
um cb is a consumption of good b
we have um a budget set essentially
which is
um uh determined here by like how much
your budget constraint which is sort of
the
triangle that uses the triangular line
that you see there
um the slope of that budget set is
determined by the relative price that's
essentially the
uh pa divided by um pb
and then we have what's called an
indifference curve which essentially is
the curve that makes us indifferent
between
uh um combinations of two goods and we
choose sort of the point on the budget
line that's the furthest out that gets
us in the furthest uh indifference curve
so that's kind of like
1401 that you should be all uh familiar
with in part that's what was discussed
in recitation
on friday now fischer then pointed out
when you think about choices over time
in fact that's exactly
um the same thing think about like two
periods period one and period two
we have essentially a budget line again
which is the budget set again that's
what was discussed in recitation on
thursday and friday
the difference here of course is then
the price the relative price is
determined by the interest rate so one
plus
r is now essentially the relative price
so one over one plus r
that determines essentially how much we
can maximally maximally consume
again like sort of the triangle that you
see is sort of the potential set that
you consume
and then again we have like a difference
curve that tell us like uh uh the sets
of points that we are different
um between between good one and good two
and we choose sort of what's furthest
out on the indifference curve
so essentially we can sort of apply any
tools that we have from 1401 or any sort
of intra micro class
from like choices between apples and
bananas to choices between
uh period one and period two
and so what we're sort of ignoring here
is then sort of in period one and period
two how we're going to spend the money
so we think of like c1 and c2 of like
consumption bundles
think about this like how much money is
spent on certain consumption goods and
period one versus period two
ignoring kind of like whether you buy
apples so bananas just how much money do
you want to spend in good one
so in period one how much money do you
want to spend in uh period two
ignoring kind of like how exactly gonna
divide it assuming that you're gonna get
this right in terms of like choosing uh
within the period
uh what's best for you any questions on
that
okay so that gets us to the from the the
workhorse model in economics which is
samuelson's discounted utility model
policy aminoson is a very famous
economist who was at mit for many many
years
um one of sort of the founders if you
want of the modern um
of modern economics and of the uh sort
of the mit economics department as it is
um right now and what samuelson um
proposed was sort of a non-graphical
version of that we said let's write down
some math let's write down a
representation
how should we think about utility
maximization
and what essentially he was proposing is
to say at time t
people maximize their discounted utility
which is just the sum of discounted
utility where there's a factor
delta which sort of determines how much
we care about the present versus the
future
right so we have essentially these
instantaneous utilities
ut your t plus one your t plus two and
so on this is your utility at each point
in time
think of time as being discrete in a
sense time could be years
time could be days so like think of them
perhaps as like years from now there's
like um
your t your t plus one your t plus two
your t plus uh
three and so on ut sort of uh summarizes
in some sense how you feel in that year
overall in terms of flag utility that
sort of utility um
in that particular period it could also
be daily it could be like how you feel
on a certain day could be hourly and so
on
um um you know that's just a matter of
um
definition now then um
and again sort of you um uh uot is sort
of a function of all activities that are
going on in that particular year that
could be consumption
leisure all other things that are going
on that's sort of like in some sense we
abstract away what happens within that
particular
time period we're just sort of
summarizing all the things you're doing
in that year you know yield to a certain
utility
and now the question is kind of like how
do we aggregate these utilities
how do we decide between different
options when the ut is
different across differ across different
options
now what's coming in here then that is
the discount factor delta
which you see above which essentially is
telling you
how much is a util or like a
a an amount of utility a unit of utility
worth that's in the future compared to
the present right
so and what you see here is there's a
very simple
functional form of doing that everything
that's in the future is discounted
usually we think of delta being like
smaller than one
so delta could be something like point
nine point eight or the like
so if you're in period t period t plus
one is discounted by
uh 0.9 uh if you're then a period three
would be then discounted sorry period
two would be then discounted by 0.9 to
the power of 2 and so on and so forth
okay and so delta is essentially a very
simple way of
of replacing like a very complex
psychology how we think about
um choices over time by saying like
let's just assume that people um over
time uh have a constant way of
discounting the future
and um it's it's sort of taken on this
simple mathematical form of like
exponentially um
uh doing so any questions on that
yes um
yes um
yeah so i think uh you know one has to
sort of think a little bit about where
things are coming from in the sense that
like
um to start with nobody had formalized
some of these choices that people were
making and some sense samus and was like
okay we have to assume something
so let's assume exponential discounting
that's a simple thing to do
so let me just sort of make that
assumption as a first pass
he actually never thought this is the
right model or like this is a normative
model how people should behave or the
like that was all coming later
he was just proposing something that's
tractable and for tractability
um he was proposing that now it's
important to understand for a lot of
behavioral economics a lot of
neoclassical economics sort of the the
traditional economics
simplicity is good so like usually we
like to simplify a lot of um
choices and uh when things are simple
you can sort of
in a tractable way analyze things in the
world and for many
problems in the world like for example
economic growth or sort of like how the
economy evolves as a whole and so on
some of these except the exponential
discounting model might actually be the
right model in some ways or if you think
about like how
managers or firms or whatever etc behave
in some ways that might be the right or
the economy as a whole
that might be the right model overall
so in some sense the answer is kind of
like a some choices are actually
explained reasonably well with
exponential discounting
b it was simple and easy to do and you
had to sort of start somewhere
and then see i guess people sort of tend
to stick to uh
traditional things so in some ways like
once you have written down a model and
people have like written papers and sort
of
invested their career in it they sort of
tend to defend that well in fact maybe
that's not the right thing to do and
become sort of like dogmatic
um about it but sort of that's now uh uh
changing and
exactly as you say there's sort of
problems with this model and we're gonna
talk about those
um right now um
now let me sort of tell you a little bit
about sort of like um some definitions
just to be clear so what we're talking
about
so one is what's a discount function
what's a discount rate and what's a
discount
um a factor so these are just definition
a discount function essentially is like
when you have a stream of future
utilities ut your t plus one your t
plus two and so on and so forth you have
to sort of write down a function how to
weigh these in the future
so d of towers as i'm calling it
essentially giving you this discount
function that specifies essentially
all the weights that you're putting on
future utilities um
uh in future periods
that could be that functional form could
be anything that's just a very general
definition now what's a discount rate
it's essentially the rate of decline of
the discount function we call that row
and row of tau
which essentially is just the derivative
with respect to time divided by the
discount function at that point in time
and the negative of that because we
think sort of usually uh uh
uh uh it's positive as in like people
tend to sort of um or the
the uh discount function tends to
decline as in like stuff that's further
away in the future you put less weight
on than stuff that's
um uh closer to you um or closer to the
present
and so again row of tau specifies the
rate at which
uh uh which value util declines to a
delay
and then finally what does exponential
discounting do well exponential
discounting
specifies a specific functional form of
the discount function
what does that mean essentially we just
take the discount function d of t
tau and what samsung was doing then was
essentially just proposing a specific
functional form of saying let's try that
one that's a simple thing
to do why do you choose that one well
it's sort of it's it's
delta to the power of tau um the
discount factor now is delta this is
like essentially
when you think about two periods how
much weight you put on each of those
periods let me just go back for a second
here when you think about like uh going
from u t to u t plus one you just add an
additional delta and going from t
u t plus one to u t plus two you add
another delta and so on
that gives you essentially the relative
weights between two adjacent
periods now crucially as you see here in
that functional form
this is like constant so every time you
have a time period you go to the future
you add another delta
and that's an assumption so that's a
very convenient thing to do and part
what it tells you then is also that the
discount rate is constant over time
again so that you could do some math and
sort of calculate the discount rate
if you sort of do that you'll find out
that the discount rate is minus
a log delta which is approximately
1 minus delta that is to say not only is
the discount factor constant but also
the discount rate
is constant and that's an assumption
again that's made by
samus so you can sort of do that math we
can also do some of that in recitation
in case you have questions now uh let me
give you an example on how does that
help us think about how people make
choices over time
um student amy uh considers writing a
term paper today so as to give off
to give herself a free evening in the
future
so uh this is essentially the idea that
like the student now
tonight has some stuff to do there's
some opportunity costs right now
um an outside option she could watch tv
she could meet her friends or whatever
or she could write her um a paper right
now
the paper if you write the paper right
now it comes at a utility cost of minus
one
it costs like one util because the other
activities would be more fun to do she'd
rather watch movies
however if instead she also has some
other stuff to do um tonight
so she doesn't really have a free
evening um if she doesn't write the
paper but she just prefers not to write
it right now
now if she writes the paper right now
she will get a free evening sometime in
the future
in a few days from now and that would be
a lot more fun she could go out she
could do whatever other things she likes
to do she could go to the symphony or
whatever she likes doing
the instantaneous benefit the utility of
getting a free unit is four thirds utils
so it's like higher than the cost right
now but it's in the future in some
future
evening suppose amy's daily discount
factor is
0.9 now what does she do how do we think
about this now
so what if the next so the daily
discount factor is 0.9
is she going to do it if the free
evening is tomorrow
yes
and that's positive or negative
uh it's positive uh okay exactly that's
exactly right so you have to think about
like okay she gets the immediate cost
right now which is minus one
the benefits of four thirds are in the
future since her daily discount factor
is 0.9 she's going to discount that by
0.9
uh that's still larger than one so she
decides to do that right that's how she
weighs essentially the current
uh uh the present and the future now in
two periods she does the exact same
thing
but two periods are like now uh further
away in the future so she discounts it
by delta to the power of two
um and that gives her um again something
that's larger than
a zero if i got the math right so still
she's willing to do it
if the um uh if the free night comes
like two nights
from now if it's in three period however
it turns out
then like minus one uh plus delta to the
power of three times four thirds
is in fact like uh uh smaller than zero
so she will not do it
so essentially when she thinks about
costs and benefits it depends a lot on
like how far away are the benefits in
the future
the further their way in the future the
more they get discounted and the less
likely she's doing something that will
cost her utility now
and yield benefits um in the future now
of course
that's highly stylized yeah
correct correct so what i was assuming
here i was not saying like when is the
best time of doing that what i was
assuming here is like
choice between today versus in a few
days from now there was no option of
saying today actually i'd rather do it
tomorrow we'll get
to that and i was just just giving you
an example of like very simple choice
between
today versus sometime in the future and
then another choice between today so
today versus tomorrow
today versus in two days from now today
versus three days from now
assuming that other days are not an
option um for now
we'll get to like so procrastination you
need sort of like several days
we'll get to that um uh later uh so
again so the bottom line
one second the bottom line she will do
it if the nice evening comes the next
period or in two periods but not if it
comes
um later yeah it doesn't in all the
periods
she gets more utility if she rather gets
a free day today
yes yeah so so what i'm assuming here
and this is again an assumption it's
that the free knight cannot search so
i was saying a little bit about the
paper apps now clearly she has something
to do
tonight anyway so she can't really have
a free night maybe she needs to call her
friends or like you know uh
and so on so that option is not
available right now you're exactly right
if the free night came tonight
she would do that and then sort of do
the thing stuff later because she
prefers the present over over the future
but i was sort of assuming that a way
for simplicity
but in general as it happens many uh
choices are often in the form of either
uh sort of current costs and future
benefits
and then you know you'd rather sort of
um defer those things um
or you you only do that essentially if
the benefits are sufficiently high
other options are like current benefits
and future costs
and then the entire thing is essentially
flipped
okay so now um the next question then we
might have is to say
well how do we actually estimate delta
right so like
um we sort of see people doing choices
but in some sense in the real world we
actually don't know what somebody's
delta is so how can we actually estimate
people's delta overall
let's sort of stick with the stylized
example what do we need um to estimate
delta in this specific example
well you would sort of need several
choices over time and then sort of
essentially you need to know what the
costs and benefits of those choices are
and if you knew that um then you could
sort of learn about um
um uh what delta is let me sort of just
write this down for you
suppose we didn't know amy's delta but
we knew that you
house for all periods for the different
options that she has
so how can we estimate this from the
above data so we learned essentially
over here
suppose we see this behavior overall
what we get is this like several
inequalities involving delta and
involving uh
uts or utaus that people choice uh
choose in different points in time
right so once we have these inequalities
then we can essentially just estimate
what is delta
um when we just back out what delta is
from these choices
so what do we do well we can just sort
of essentially do the math it's very
simple
and what we'll find is like if you see
for example if you see that
the behavior that we just saw which was
essentially
that she does it uh when the free night
comes uh one day from now or two nights
two days from now uh that gives us two
inequalities the first two inequalities
that wrote down
and then um which is essentially delta
must be larger than three
three quarters delta must be larger than
three quarters uh to the power of one
half which is about point
eight seven and then we have a third
choice where she
uh doesn't do it if the free knight
comes three nights from now which gives
us another inequality which sort of
tells us delta
must be uh lower than 0.91
so if you sort of saw those choices but
if you knew the utility
of a person we could then sort of back
out what delta is and delta in this case
would be between 0.87 and 0.91
does this make sense or any questions
about that
so all of us doing here is to say
suppose we didn't know delta but we just
saw the
amy's choices what can we learn about
her delta if you knew sort of what the
utilities are at each point in time
right and if we do that we essentially
get
from this behavior we get these
inequalities and we can then back out
what the delta is now in reality we
actually don't know what the u taus are
we don't we don't know what the
utility is for different options from
people so if you see people's behavior
we can actually estimate delta
from that so what what what could we do
instead or what kind of choices can we
make
or can be elicited
yes
right and what what additional
assumptions do we need for that
so that's exactly right that's exactly
what people have done a lot
um so we have the this is like the
sailor again a nobel prize winner who
was
done exactly that in uh in 1981
uh giving people to start with
hypothetical monetary choices
just to say suppose um this is kind of
what i was asking you at the beginning
in the first class i was asking you
uh different numbers but what make what
x makes you indifferent between 15
today and x dollars in you know a month
a year and 10 years from now
uh what do we need to assume for that
now or like what other assumptions do we
need
like how do we go from money to the
utility
exactly i need to assume uh something
that's quite important here i need to
assume sort of uh
utilities linear and money either sort
of to say i'm sort of just looking at
that specific problem u of x
equals x or slightly more complicated
but in principle the same
marginal utility is sort of constant um
over time so in some sense
that's sort of related for our purposes
what we're going to assume for now is
just to say you have um
uh your utilities linear and money u of
x equals x
and then what you can do is if you give
me an amount
um i give you an amount y y is fifteen
dollars right and then i ask you um what
makes you a difference between x dollars
and say a month or year from now
i'm just going to write down an equation
which essentially is to say
u of y which is the utility of getting
the 15 right now
is uh you're indifferent between that
because you just told me so
and u of x which acts as the amount that
you just told me
and now i need to discount that by delta
to the power of t which is like because
it's in the future um
you need to discount that once i know
that i know essentially everything on
the left-hand side and the right-hand
side of the equation
except for the delta i can just back out
delta
from that okay so what we're going to do
is we're going to just use then the
linear
the linearity assumption of the utility
is
linear in money which is like u of y
equals y and u of x equals x
we take sort of logs on both sides and
rearrange and then get like rho
which is again like the discount rate
equals minus log delta and that's like
log of x
divided by y and divided by uh t which
is like the time period
um that i'm asking you about that's just
simple algebra
i'm sort of rearranging things um we
talked about this a little bit in
in recitation and in the problem set as
well but is it clear what we're doing
here or any questions about that
so just to summarize what i'm doing here
i'm just saying like i'm asking you
between different choices over time
i'm assuming a utility function of money
so i'm sort of imposing on you in some
way that might be good or a bad
assumption but i'm essentially sort of
assuming
how you value money at different points
in time and without assumption then
i can back out from your choices over
time how much you're discounting
utility in the future right and then the
rest is just sort of like
um rearranging and and and doing some
math
okay so now how do you do that um here's
an example of how to do that then for y
equals 15 and x equals 20. so if you
told me that what makes you
uh and different between 15 now and x
dollars in a month if you told me 20
i could just write down the equation and
i get essentially a delta of
zero three the reason being that like if
you are
indifferent between fifteen dollars and
twenty dollars right now
uh you essentially um your discount
you're discounting essentially anything
that's in the future by like three
quarters
like essentially twenty dollars in a
month from now or like three quarters
or the money right now is like or the
money in the future is three quarters
extra month's worth for you than the
money right now that's a 20 versus 15 in
a month from now
and then i have to do this every month
so like every month it's like three
quarters for the power of 12 will give
you something like point zero
zero uh point zero three uh uh as delta
so i'm just sort of like calculating the
um uh
a yearly discount factor uh uh using
sort of your monthly choice
right so usually what people do is like
yearly discount factors so usually the
delta is yearly
that's just a convention you could also
do it monthly or daily or whatever
so what i'm doing is like yearly
discount factors partially because i
want them to make
i want to make them comparable um across
across choices but you could similarly
also just do the monthly one or whatever
and a lot of economic analyses sort of
yearly a sort of like a
a frequency when it comes to your
problem set questions you're going to be
like daily because you know students
tend to think in days not necessarily in
in years
right um so i mean in some sense uh uh
this is what we're getting here in some
ways and saying like
here i'm asking you about um so you see
the choice here when you and these are
actually real choices that people have
made
when i ask you now between x dollars
right now and
sorry between why dollars 15 right now
and x dollars and 10 years from now
people tend to give different answers
and one constant finding there is that
people tend to be more
patient when it comes to longer run
choices compared to like shorter run
choices
right i'm calculating the same discount
factor and what i just told you earlier
is like
in the exponential discounting model the
discount factor delta
should be constant over time to be the
same
whether you decide between today and
tomorrow between like a year now and a
year
year from now and a year and a day from
now or between any time
in the future but what we find or tend
to find in these kinds of choices is
that
people's discount factor is a lot higher
in the future
compared to in the present i'll get back
to that so actually
your question is exactly on point um
when
eliciting choices between different days
versus month versus years
you get a lot different answers compared
to uh
depending on what you ask
okay so now we can sort of say this is
exactly what you're asking well let's
just see like when you do this in
different settings
what kinds of answers do you actually
get and what you see here is here's sort
of like people's choices of delta and
different types of
experiments people have done this is
different years of publication
but overall what you see is essentially
these estimates are all over the place
so you sort of think you know we know
what delta is we think it's like 0.9 or
0.8 or 0.95 or whatever
but in fact when you look at people's
choices um and different types of
experiments
these choices tend to be all over the
place so that's not a good sign for a
model because you're trying to sort of
identify a parameter that essentially is
sort of
um that fits many settings well here it
seems to be that um
you know these choices are essentially
all over the place which sort of tells
you already maybe something is wrong in
this model that we should try to
um fix now
one thing i already said here is to say
when you look at
short run versus long run choices we
tend to find that people are really
impatient in the short run
however people are patient in the long
run
there's lots to learn from this
experiment in various ways in part
um about sort of strategies to overcome
self-control problems for example a lot
of kids were trying to manage their
attention not looking at it looking away
and so on
but mostly i think the key part you sort
of learn is like how painful it can be
to resist in the short run there's lots
of essentially um
short run discounting or essentially
short-run inpatient that we see in the
world and if you think about it
often it's very hard in the short run to
resist often when you think about in the
future it's much easier
to do so when you think about choices
that you might face in your life
you know be it marshmallows or something
else would you rather have like one
marshmallow right now versus two
marshmallows in an
hour you might say well maybe my
marshmallow looks actually pretty good
let's just take the marsh one
marshmallow right now and a lot of these
kids i guess
opted for doing so when i ask you
instead
would you like to have a marshmallow in
a week from now versus two marshmallows
in a week from now in an hour a dollar
this comes like ridiculous of course
you're gonna take two marshmallows in
like um uh
a week and an hour from now what does it
matter like in terms of wendy exactly
you got the marshmallow
i'm gonna ask you the same questions
about uh one marshmallow in a year from
now versus one
two marshmallows in a year and an hour
from now it becomes very obvious that
like of course i want the two
marshmallows unless you think in a year
from now uh you might be on a diet
so um but you know the exponential
discounting model has precisely that
assumption the assumption is that
how much you discount an hour in this
case does not vary
uh depending on whether it's right now
whether it's in the week from now versus
whether it's in a year from now
and sort of uh the short run discounting
sort of essentially tends to
violate that assumption in part because
it leads to pretty absurd implications
as i'm going to show you um in a bit so
what other evidence in the world do we
have about short run in patients
than the marshmallows
yes
right there's lots of i think among you
guys not that many um
um people smoke but lots of smokers
would say
oh i'd love to stop smoking and in the
future
like really want to quit um but then um
you know they find it very hard to do
right now and maybe next time in the
future i will quit and so on and so
forth
lots of people try and then fail and so
on and exactly um
uh and part it's sort of like the short
run impatience or short run difficulty
to to do that
uh compared maybe the long run desires
if wanted to do so we'll get back to
smoking actually at some point um
in the future but that's exactly a great
example of that that's also true for
other drugs other addictions
and so on actually some of the social
media or computers or phones or whatever
you can also think of like that being
sort of addictive in a sense in the
short run it's very hard to get away
from that
but in the very long run it would be
nice thing to do often than there's like
short-run impatience
um involved yeah
yeah so like a break now always seems
like a great idea and then you know in
the future you're gonna work really hard
and so on um
and then you know the future comes and
then again like taking a break right now
uh uh seems really um appealing yeah
that's interesting can you say more
people trying to get to um as fast as
possible
right so of course there's also like
other factors involved including like
risk and the like you know you might
sort of think you know you underestimate
how risky it is and like you might think
oh i might be overconfident that you
know you're never going to have an
accident
but exactly as you say in the short run
essentially there's some short-run
benefits which is like you know you'd be
there faster it's kind of annoying to
drive and so on and so forth
um uh the costs are in the future and
some sins are uncertain
you know they might crash and so on um
and sort of
uh you might be impatient in the very
short run that's right but i think
that's a little tricky as an example
because there's all these other factors
i do think however that uh short-run
impatience is involved in that as well
yes yeah i think credit cards are also
good examples like you can buy this now
with a credit card
instead of saving to buy the team
yes so a lot of essentially choices of
money over time
you can sort of see the choices that i
was asking you guys in class that
essentially show some short run in
patients um
as well um there's uh
perhaps even more salient sort of payday
loans that you might be familiar with
so payday loans are essentially a very
interesting phenomenon where essentially
there are workers who get their paycheck
by the end of the month or the beginning
of the month but then on the 20th
20th of the month or sometime earlier
they would like to have some money
earlier than that
so you can essentially just say give me
some money at a very high interest rate
once my payday come i'm gonna pay you
back
uh the interest rates are usually
enormous usually it's something like up
to like 5 000
annualized compound interest which is
like insane
these are like huge interest rates it's
also now like enormous industry in the
us
it's like more stores than mcdonald's
and starbucks combines which i'm not
sure how many stores there are but i
think there's lots of them
um and you know people pay huge interest
rates um and it's a huge industry of
doing that
what's kind of funny about payday loans
in some ways is actually
in some ways it's an odd thing of the
world but that's sort of an aside as in
like workers have worked already for 20
days in some sense the employer owes
them money
but instead you know they're essentially
taking loans um from a salary that's
actually in some sense theirs already
anyway
in various ways but that's just an aside
so that's a huge interest
industry you were saying something
similar which is credit card debt
usually they're the annual interest rate
is sort of like lower than that it's
something like 20 20
in many cases you know sometimes also
higher uh there's lots of credit card
debt in the us and you can think of this
as like essentially
signs of short run and patient what you
see is that patients what you see is
like um people
wanting to spend spend many money now on
various things
and they get the gains of doing that the
cost of that comes sometime in the
future when you actually have to pay it
back
right um finally there's also some
evidence of like payday effects these
are
often um involved in things like um
people for example who get food stamps
or any other sort of like
monthly or or other sort of cash
transfers where people get either
food stamps or money at some point
conditional unconditional
cash transfers at the beginning of the
month and then usually there are these
cycles and consumption or
expenditures where at the beginning of
the month people live large and have
lots of money
same is also true for graduate students
on their stipends uh the first weeks or
months
after uh getting your paychecks often is
really great
and then it sort of declines over the
course of of that cycle
the same is also true by the way for
farmers and harvest cycles in india and
other places
and then usually towards the end of the
cycle people either like hungry have low
caloric intake or just not
um very happy that's a very common
phenomenon
and sort of at the heart of that there
is some short run in patience in the
sense like at the beginning of the month
you're really impatient want to consume
some stuff and sort of discount what's
in the end of the cycle what's further
away
where the costs are coming then uh in
terms of like not having enough
resources or money um
available anymore uh here's sort of
some examples of payday loans uh i was
wondering what this woman uh i was uh
this is from wongam.com apparently there
are
advertising with like grandmothers and
because you wonder what this woman is
doing there
but what you see here on the very right
hand side is like essentially uh the
interest rates are something in the
thousand percent these are the
annualized interest rates
these are enormous interest rates
usually people
take many loans of that they also take
repeated loans so it's not just there's
an emergency where people take a loan
but people tend to like roll over these
loans over and over again and actually
pay lots and lots of money um
uh to these companies there's often very
high credit card
aprs which you know 20 25
and so on are very common again lots of
people have lots of credit card debt
and often it's again not just sort of to
deal with trucks you might say well if
you have a health shock or some other
shock in the family if people get
perhaps unemployed for a short period of
time maybe that's
that sort of makes sense to sort of deal
with that shock but often people tend to
roll over
um uh this interest like for many many
cycles
and keep paying these really high
interest rates
now in some sense that's just empirical
evidence that's just a fact that these
things exist
however um when you sort of think that
through you get very
um absurd implications of this short run
in patients so what i showed you now is
like several pieces of evidence of short
run
and patience now sort of taking the
exponential discounting model very
seriously
we're going to think about some of these
implications of what does the
exponential discounting model sort of
say
implies from that and sort of one way to
think about this is the money now versus
later choices as i told you before
um uh when you look at number one here i
was asking you about what makes you
indifferent between hundred dollars now
and x dollars in two weeks
and the median student was saying
something like 120 115
um dollars and you can think about like
what does that imply for the yearly um
delta
well it implies for the yearly delta
that it's about five over six
right so you're like you're indifferent
between hundred dollars now versus
hundred twenty dollars in the future
so that must mean like uh the future is
like five six
as much worth as the present is for you
right now
right now that's fine but that's sorry
so excuse me that was like the uh two
weeks so that i was i was asking you
about
a hundred dollars now versus x dollars
in two weeks from now
so the two-week delta is five over six
now you can think about what does that
mean for like your
um uh uh four-week delta well it's
five-sixths to the power of two
what does that mean between for your um
uh so that's essentially you're
indifferent between hundred dollars now
and 144 dollars and four weeks from now
you're also in different between 100
now and 11 400 in a year from now
and you're also in different between 100
now and i don't even know what that
number is but a very very large
number so if you so think the discount
factor is delta and you sort of just
roll that forward
um you get essentially absurd
implications the reason being that we
assume sort of that the discount
factor is constant and sort of then
essentially if you are
reasonably impatient between the present
and sort of anytime
in the near future like two or four
weeks from now that must imply that you
really really don't care about what's
happening and five years from now um
and so on now that's completely
unrealistic
the discount factor for two weeks delays
in the future must be in some ways
higher than the discount factor for two
weeks delays in the present and that's
essentially what the quasi-hyperbolic or
the model i'm going to propose to you in
the next class
is going to try and explain so why is
that
unrealistic well we know from many
situations in the world people care a
lot about the future right
people say for retirement people invest
in education people exercise often
people do problem sets people brush
their teeth
people eat healthy and so on people
invest a lot in the future
and and stuff that happens you know four
five six seven ten years from now
so they care a lot about the future in
some ways yet we sort of find the short
run in patients
so now we need to find sort of some
model that sort of can bridge um uh uh
this gap
and so um another way to put this is
like when you look at
um the evidence that we have in terms of
like uh by time horizon when you look at
discount factors
conducted in studies such as the one
that
i just showed you or like using real
world decisions
what you see usually is that the
discount factor in the very short run
tends to be very
small this is like what you see on the
left hand side of the graph
when you look at further in the future
the discount factor tends to be higher
or another way to put this is the
estimated delta increases by
time horizon again that's a violation of
the exponential discounting
model okay
so that's sort of the first piece of
evidence the second one is preference
reversal dynamic inconsistency
what i mean by that is dynamic
consistency essentially the property
that
when you make a choice for the future
between two future periods
and when the future then comes absent
new information or any sort of other
things that have happened
you will stick to that choice like a
formal decision a definition here is
like the action a person thinks she
should
take in the future always coincides with
the action that she actually prefers to
take once the time
comes okay so make if i make a plan to
exercise tomorrow or if i make a plan to
eat salad tomorrow
i'm gonna actually do that i'm not gonna
be like actually like watching movies
seems like a good idea
or the potato chips instead look better
like i have perfect four sides and what
i'm going to plan for the future
i know my future preferences and my
future preferences for what i want for
the future
coincide with what i what i actually
want in the future
um as well and so put differently
there's no
intrapersonal conflicts that is to say
what i want for the future
is also what the future wants my future
self wants for
um itself and so um
that's sort of close closely connected
to the assumption of exponential
discounting
that is to say exponential discounting
has the assumption that
how much i care between the present and
the future is always like
the weight is always determined by delta
and that delta doesn't change over time
so when i think about now about what i
want in the future between a year from
now and two years from now
the difference between those or the
discounting will always be delta
once the future comes the difference
between a year from then
and two years or at the time then it
will be like the present and the year
from now will also be delta so there's
no difference
um there so what's sort of the formal
argument of the exponential discounting
model
well it is essentially if at time zero i
prefer an action a
over an action b suppose there's
different actions there's action a and
action b
that i can do starting in period one
well if i prefer action a over action b
on the left hand side there's sort of
the utilities associated with that
there's u
zero plus delta times ua u1
a of action a plus delta squared of u2
of action a and so on if i prefer that
over action b well it must be that i
prefer the stream of utility on the left
hand side
to the stream of utility on the
right-hand side right
but now that implies if i sort of take
away the u0 because they're the same on
both sides because you know i'm making
choices for the future
but now and then divide by a delta what
i get is essentially
again an inequality that at time a at
time 1
again i still prefer course a or option
a
over option b that is to say if i prefer
option a over option b at time 0
that implies essentially that i also
prefer option a over option b
at time 1. so that essentially is
another way to say is that
the exponential discounting factor
implies
time and consistency any questions about
that
so what examples do we have that
violates this property we already talked
about this a bit in the previous classes
but
just to remind ourselves
yes the betting on how much weight you
lose with
your diet like you think in the future
that you'll
want to change your uh
exactly so dieting in general seems a
great example of him saying like i
really would like to
lose some weight or have some target
weight or some target exercising or
certain behavior of eating and
exercising or combined
and i really would like to do that for
now i mean i think about the future
often at new year's or
certain points of the year birthdays and
so on people think okay i'm going to do
this
i have great plans and so on they have
certain preferences for the future
but then the future comes a week or
months from then you know people
don't follow through exactly that's
essentially
a clear example of a preference reversal
which is essentially another way of
saying
preferences are dynamically inconsistent
any other example
yes
exactly so that's true for do you say
exercising
yeah for exercising exactly sort of
often uh
i'll show you some examples of people
for example signing up for gyms they pay
like yearly membership fees and so on
that tends to be very expensive
uh the idea often is then they think
about like uh uh
they will go to the gym you know weekly
or daily or whatever
uh and then under that assumption for
your preferences for the future
that it makes a lot of sense but then
you know if you then
not actually go or if your preferences
are different then it turns out to be
different in the future
that's a pretty bad idea yes you're
saying
yeah to be clear like um if you
just start eating apples because you had
too many bananas in the past
that's not what we were talking about so
it's not about um people's
uh you know past choices affecting
future choices through some form of
habit formation or people getting bored
or tired or
like but it's about if i today choose
today i want bananas tomorrow i want
apples and then tomorrow i'm actually
saying like actually i don't like
apples i really like bananas then that
would be a violation
but it needs to be something that's
essentially either like new information
or something that i
didn't uh some new options or so on that
become available
um in the example that you were
mentioning there was none of that
so that's um that's not quite what we're
talking about sort of
more common isn't there's a paper on
that does this in fact with dutch
employees
uh by reid and van noyvan that
essentially asked people about next week
first so it asked them about this is
actually
an actual company where workers ask
would
after lunch would you like to have a
snack and what snack would you like to
have
would you like to have apples or
chocolate when you ask to do that today
for next week
74 chose like food or apples essentially
so lots of people tend to like want to
be virtuous in the future eat healthily
and so on
when you ask them then the same question
so then they in the actual experiment
what they did is then they um they went
back to the workers and said oh i forgot
your choice why don't you like choose
again
let us know that was a little bit
cheating um but then essentially 70
percent of people when it comes for
uh the same day um choose um uh
chocolate
right and here's like none of that in
the sense of like there's no
habit formation there's no sort of
people ate too many apples and now they
really want chocolate that was only like
one choice
and so now when i make some choices for
the future and the future comes
you i should stick to that choice
similarly there's sort of movie choices
it used to be um
uh you guys are i'm probably too young
for this uh and netflix netflix
used to send you a movies um to your
home and what often lots of people had
was this issue they had great plans of
watching highbrow or like sort of high
culture or
and sort of often you know um a sad or
deep movies in the future
uh there's really things they wanted to
watch be like the piano schindler's list
and so on
which sort of um by some category we
might call highbrow
but instead you know when the present
comes people often like to watch
essentially um
uh lowbrow movies like comedies um and
so on and so forth
for example uh for weddings and a
funeral speed and so on for action
movies or the like
and then what would happen in netflix
often is you would get all these movies
and that you know you'd really love to
watch in the future but
you know never in the present then get
sort of stuck with them
um and there's in fact an example in a
paper who does this who essentially
elicits
people's preferences for what they would
like to watch in the present versus in
the future
and what you see essentially is people
tend to systematically
pick for the present for tonight people
tend to watch or want to watch like
lowbrow movies
you know action rom-com or whatever
sounds really good for tonight
when you think about what would you like
to watch next week people tend to
pick highbrow movies instead
okay there's lots of examples of of that
kind
now the third piece and so just to
summarize so these preference reversal
again these are not really possible in
the exponential discounting model
that should not occur that's by
assumption not possible in that model
as i just showed you before yet we see
plenty of examples in the real world
now the third piece of evidence is
demand for commitment that's really
closely related to that
so one example here is demand for
commitment is essentially is
when you know that your future
preferences will be
different from your present preferences
you might engage in commitment devices
what does that mean um you might want to
sort of like change the prices of your
options in the future and particularly
you might want to take away some options
in the future one example is alyssa's
and the sirens
who knows that story or can tell me what
it is
yes
yes exactly so here's alyssa's i think
he was like on his way back from his uh
long journey um he was um
he he knew that the sirens were gonna
come he knew that like his preferences
would change in the future that he would
not be able to resist their um
uh uh their power or their songs and so
what he did is he asked his um
his crew to sort of like bind him to the
mass so he would not be able to
leave the ship even if he wanted to in
the future that's demand for commitment
because he was taking away some options
in the future
um with a goal to change his future
behavior
knowing that his preferences would
change in the future um
his um if you wonder kind of like why
the guys who are rowing are not sort of
leaving the ship they had like wax in
their ears
i don't know why olyssus couldn't use
the wax either but anyway um
but anyway so that's one examples of a
commitment device there's another one
which is sort of financial advice that
people often get which is the following
cut up your credit card and store
the cards if possible
get rid of all your credit cards um or
put temptation out of reach
if you really can't do without a credit
card limit yourself to one put it in a
tub of water and stick it in the freezer
and so the idea here is like if you
really have sort of like timing or
if you really have like self-control
problems well when you want to sort of
buy something really quickly when
temptation sort of takes over you have
to sort of limit your
options in some ways so in some sense
have you some cooldown period it takes a
while to get your credit card
out of the freezer i don't know i i
asked my wife about like this is a thing
and she was saying like well haven't you
watched confessions of a shopaholic
i have not um if you want to watch that
video um you see in fact apparently that
is in fact uh
uh a thing but the idea of like having
having some cool down
period which essentially is like um uh
to deal with essentially short run
impatience
uh comes in many settings in many
variations in fact for example if you
like to get married
um often you have to sort of like go to
some office and say declare that you
would like to get married and then
i wait for another three days or
something until you can actually get
married
often the idea is you know people um
sometimes come to their senses
and it takes a few um days um
okay so um
so what do these examples show well they
show that um people have a tendency for
immediate gratification
and so um uh and they tend to sort of
discount quite heavily um
um uh in in short-term decisions
now what is the demand for commitment
then show it's like we in fact tend to
disapprove of this tendency uh
uh uh beforehand right that's to say we
know that in the future we might be
impatient
we don't like that and because of that
we bind ourselves to the mast or
um we freeze our credit cards or some
people um
at least do um
and so all of these decision makers are
time inconsistent in the sense that like
when they make certain choices for the
future what they will want to choose in
the future will be different
and knowing that they will restrict
their options as that is to say
different selves want different things
okay so then um what's the heart of the
issue then well the heart of the issue
is that there are conflicts rooted
between short and long one patients
what we want in the short run is
different from what we want in the long
run
that is to say when we think ahead of
the future we tend to be very patient
there's all sorts of good things we want
to do in the future
when we think about or when the time
actually comes when we think about the
presence we tend to be
impatient now the issue with exponential
discounting then is
well the exponential discounting model
has only one parameter which
captures essentially discounting but it
can sort of
by assumption the discounting needs to
be the same across all time horizons
that is to say it can only match one of
those two things but not both
right it can only uh match either like
your short run discounting but then the
long run discounting is off
or you can try to match the long run
discounting but then the short run
discounting is off
so what that sort of tells us well that
tells us we need like two parameters to
to to deal with that so what we want and
i'll talk about this a lot more in the
next class
um or next few minutes and then the next
class we want a model that has greater
patience for trade-offs in the future
than for trade-offs in the present
and then we want another model that also
so one is we want like different
uh levels of patients over different
time horizons
and we want a model that sort of
explains or helps us explain dynamic
inconsistency
so what is that model so i just showed
you before
the exponential discounting model that's
just what i showed you before above
that's exactly the same
where essentially your discounted
or lifetime utility is essentially
what's given here where we have delta
it's between zero and one and delta is a
short term discount factor
and it's a long run discount factor
right if i'm trying to sort of
decide between t and t plus one the
difference between that is essentially
delta and if i decide between t plus
three and t plus 4
it's also delta that regulates this this
factor
now what what does the quasi-hyperbolic
discounting model do it has another
parameter
okay and this parameter is called beta
and
beta governs essentially short-run
discounting
well delta is the long-run discount
factor what is that
telling us essentially beta essentially
discounts anything that's in the future
so essentially if you look at this
equation now anything that's in the
future that's not period t
is like discounted by beta and then
within any future periods we have
another discount factor that's
essentially the long run discount factor
that's delta
now why does that help us well it helps
us because now we can essentially
separate short run and long run
discounting
we can say short run discounting is
governed by beta
and long run discounting is is governed
by delta
and now we can match a lot of facts that
we couldn't
match earlier any questions
on that
yeah i was wondering if the evidence
on this was compatible
right right so you're asking like two
separate questions here so one question
is
can we explain and theory commitment
devices can be explained essentially can
we write down a theory that says
you should be at least under some
assumptions under some parameters
uh willing to engage in commitment
devices and demand for commitment
the answer is yes depend depending a
little bit on your naivete and
sophistication which we're going to get
to
but so you in principle at least can in
theory write stuff write down
a version of this model that predicts
demand for commitment
you're asking a separate question which
is like is is are these commitment
devices actually going to help
are people going to so hey i guess are
people are going to make use of these
commitment devices and b
are they going to help the answer is
like maybe in many situations in fact
no the reason being often people then
they might sort of demand commitment but
then not follow through in various ways
which can be then explained by people
who are sort of overconfident when it
comes to their self-control problems
we're going to talk about this next time
so the idea here is that
people might understand that they have
self-control problems they might demand
commitment devices might say i'd like to
have a commitment advice to help me
but they might underestimate how bad
their self-control problems actually are
so then they demand the commitment
device that's actually kind of helpful
but not quite uh
enough that's not powerful enough they
demand that commitment device but then
they actually fail
and do the thing they want to do anyway
and essentially have to pay money or
other things
like that we'll talk about that but
that's sort of like that's not a
theoretical problem that's like an
empirical problem in the sense of like
in principle uh commitment devices
should help they might not be able to do
so
in practice well let me tell you a
little bit more about sort of
specific of the model and then we're
going to talk about this in more detail
next time so usually we tend to assume
that beta is
lower than one and delta is close to one
so for example we think like beta is
like two-thirds
or three-quarters of the like and delta
equals one
so then your discounted utility becomes
something like this
um so relative to the current period all
future periods are worth
a much less so everything in the future
essentially you discount by two-thirds
and then within any future periods you
don't discount very much anymore
usually we think sort of like delta is
like 0.99
0.95 with the likes so there's like some
discounting in the future you care more
about like
stuff that's like one year from now
compared to like 10 years from now or 30
years from now
but not that much differently you care a
lot about whether stuff is like in the
present versus in two weeks from now or
in a year from from now um
okay and so then um uh similarly you
know if beta equals one half and delta
equals one
then again like your discount function
this is the d of tau that i was writing
you down earlier
is essentially you care about the
present one and then everything in the
future is like um
one half so again relative to the
present uh
all future periods are worth less weight
one half
and then all discounting takes a place
between the present and the immediate
future
okay so then again what we can explain
now is essentially
short run impatience i'm essentially
impatient between the present and the
future anything that's in the future is
essentially far away or like gets the
weight of like in this case like one
half or like two thirds of the leg
i can also explain long run patients
because essentially
uh across years in the future there's no
discounting happening anymore people
tend to be
um relatively patient and so then uh
decisions of course are very sensitive
um to the timing and
costs and benefits we're going to talk
about that um
next time so um as i said in the email i
sent you readings until next until
wednesday are the odonical raven
paper we're going to discuss or finish
the same set of slides that i've given
you
now let me know if you have any
questions thank you
you